so let me just call you my back a little
bit because it's been some time since we
looked at this I want you to remember
but we particularly covered two kinds of
sequences in series I want you to recall
if I gave you something like say well
it's not something we it's not something
like three
here's a sequence he's a sequence it's a
secret scannable adding anything up it's
just a list of numbers in order
he's the secrets and you can see that
between each of the numbers there's a
common of difference of false right a
common difference in four and so you add
for every time so what kind of sequence
is this do remember it's an ad many
major and I made progression was that
word that I gave to you right
tell me P similarly I could come up with
something like let's do it this way
we'll start the same
that's what how about this
this and this so I've given you extra
terms only really to give you three as
you print out before but I've given you
a chance just to make it a little more
obvious here there is not a common
difference instead you have a common
ratio you're multiplying by a number
each time in this case yeah we call it a
geometric progression because there is a
common ratio the common ratio in this
case is negative 2 so what we decided
was or what we worked out was and there
are nice neat ways to think about these
if you like
ah what's the what's the Sun what's the
series if I take the first a thousand
bees or a million of them you for an MPD
you member you pair up the toes I'm
sorry you pair up the first loss the
second in the second last and so on
everything's nice with this one do you
remember what we had to do if I said ok
here's a series right if you multiply
everything by that common ratio right so
if I say what are we said to come right
here was negative 2 so if I multiply
everything by that then every term turns
into the next term right so this thing
in flu will turn into a 6 this will turn
into a negative 12 this 11 to 24 and so
on okay and because you can match up
these terms you can again find the sum
of the series in quite a nice neat way
but not all sequences series are a piece
or GPS in fact one of the important
examples I gave you was this guy what's
this guy in it this is the Fibonacci
sequence which is neither an AP Norwich
ep but it's one of the first sequences
you're know it's quite easy to wrap your
head around and it's quite simple to
come up with different sequences that
are nothing here is olan and I think
this actually appears as again one of
the questions in their chapter this is
the sequence of
that's where numbers right and there
isn't a comma difference there is at the
common ratio so how do you deal with
these things when you don't have the
nice the patterns that we established
before okay we're going to look for
different patterns so the question that
allows you to look at how it might help
if we actually write this down first was
this one was number seven and it looked
like this
what's this 325 I think
okay so this is what they want us to add
up and it just looks weird it's all
kinds of we can practice their kind of
difference there's their common ratio
so how are we gonna deal with this thing
what we are able to do is to try and
sense all right well we used some tools
before to sense the pattern hyung right
we can do something similar to sense the
pattern here if we can get something
that will show us oh yeah you can pair
these things up or you can cancel these
things out it would be exactly the same
as these guys can slow their pain it's
not a GP but there are other things we
can do so I want to take the problem or
the strategies rather that I suggested
you right in the first lesson to try and
look at this thing and there are no
words in it but it's just as
problem-solving and unfamiliar as that
thing with though or wasn't the guy with
three three children and we have to try
and work out their ages to remember that
in the violin right so what kinds of
things did we do that well I think the
first thing was we wanted to dissect the
problem remember that it just looks
weird and imposing so how can we break
this down a little bit okay what I want
to notice is a UH a problem like this is
always set up to be deceptive because
there's an unknown number of terms but
every term looks the same do you notice
that they will follow a pattern which is
the whole idea this one I think this one
in this one how do you get from one term
to the next what do you do to advance or
what to enter it
each one of those thieves of the design
it is by the way we have language for
this rather say things or what what are
these they're factors in a product so
each one of these factors we add one to
it we increase it by whether it turns
into this and then each of these factors
we increase it by what it turns into
this and you do it until such a time as
you get to whichever value of K you like
about 100 or 1000 or something like that
but because you're making each of the
factors advance one right the gap
between the factors is always 2 and the
next one will be 4 and 6 then the next
one will be 5 and 7 and so on which is
why the K term is K and K plus 2
does that make sense so what I want to
do is just taste think that let's just
look at this guy every single term is in
this form so how can I work out what's
going on there what makes this term this
time whatever k k plus 2 I want you to
consider something like this
for adding you if I asked you to add
these two fractions together what will
be the first thing that you do you would
go for a common denominator what did you
so you're like I can't get these two
factions to talk to each other in two
thirds and fits so I'll get them to be
in this case if you've dates right so
it'll look for I'll write this as 5 over
3 minus 5 I know that you know what that
is you can just go straight there but
I'm trying to put something out here and
then this guy you write as would write
that is if he seeks over again 3 times 5
so what I'm noticing is the primary
reasons you get fractions which have
like lots of things on the denominator
extra factors on the denominator like
this is when you combine two fractions
right if you were to add or subtract two
fractions together then you sort of have
to do this by necessity you multiply the
donuts so you can get a common one right
so if we think about this what / kk + 2
what kind of pair of fractions where is
have come from now I don't know so I'm
just gonna take a stab at the dark this
is again is ale a classic problem
solving strategy just try something
let's see what happens at the very least
you see this guy here it came from
fractions with those denominators so why
do I try taking those guys K and K + 2
here's a pair of fractions it has those
individual debilities so when I put the
together maybe I'll get something that
looks like that so let's try it when you
add these two together
consider because I just try to think
this thing through and throw some things
at the wall and see what sticks okay but
they're not just random it's an educated
guess what are you going to get the
common denominator is going to be K
times k plus 2 but what will this do you
better become the first one k plus 2
right
because that's what you want to play the
top one by what about the second
fraction okay
okay now what I have a look at this this
gets the denominator that I wanted but I
don't even need to go much further like
in terms of simplify this numerator you
can see I'm going to get two K plus 2
which looks nothing really like this
okay
2k plus 2 all I supposed to have is a
number up there bouquets or anything
like that the case have crept up because
of x z z-- so how would I overcome them
well I add those fractions before I
added them which is why this and this
combined in this unfortunate way but
that's not the only thing I can do right
if I if I don't want it Kay's or the top
do you see this he can't hear it okay
there I can get them to actually kids
each other out cut I instead of adding
the fractions together why did I try
subtracting if I multiply if I multiply
I do have this but then I don't I mean
when things are multiplied together I
don't have something that's much simpler
than what I've already gone okay
whereas if I have something that's added
up or subtracted you see this is a
little bit subtracted so I'm hoping for
something the kids allowed so I'm gonna
write the subtraction instead let's try
this what is going to happen well it's
going to be exactly the same thing
except with a minus sign instead of a
possible so I'm gonna get this
and this doesn't seem like it's all that
helpful just yet but let's click on it
and play with it a little bit on the
numerator the k's are gonna cancel so
what will we be left with okay
it's too I actually put one don't I
that's what I really wanted
so being that this is what I started
with if it turns into until the deer
area and I want it to be a one I'm just
going to attend equation I'm just going
to divide both sides by two
does that make sense and I'll get the
feelin that one so I'm going to divide
this by two I just saw just just think
hot at the front and that one term is
it's one do you have to admit now I
would you again come back to a couple
weeks ago do but we spend a long time
factorizing do you remember that
and we said factorizing was useful
because you can reveal the structure of
an object if you know its factors right
well I tried to do something a little
bit in Reverse I'll try to break up
something which has been factorized into
different kinds of pieces here's why if
I can stay this as two pieces not one
but each of the pieces is simpler and
there's a subtraction only if I bring
that to bear up here something's will
cancel out